we're a culture that's highly attuned to
what's beautiful and moving about love
we know it's high points and celebrate
its ecstasy's in films and songs by
comparison work is the dull tedious bit
the thing we have to do to pay the bills
and yet what's striking is how often
work despite its lack of glamour in fact
turns out to be the easier more
enjoyable and ultimately more humane
part of life there are a number of
reasons work demands that all who walk
through the office door must behave
professionally and what behaving
professionally essentially means is that
situations where you're deep inside
tempted to explode insult curse and weep
require you to handle yourself with
stoic calm and reserved at work you
can't really be yourself and nor can
others around you which could sound a
little fake and therefore inauthentic
and plastic but this lack of honesty may
in fact be an extremely welcome
development after we've spent a little
too long in an atmosphere where everyone
feels a duty to be utterly frank
and an uncensored correspondent of their
every inner mood and qualms the
assumption of most jobs is that people
who begin them don't have the first clue
about what's going on you're not
expected to know the machinery or the
protocols by intuition alone therefore
you're sent on training programmes and
given extensive manuals to read it might
be two years before you're supposed to
understand very much at all there is no
such luxury
for lovers who are meant to get one
another by immediate instinct and take a
speedy comprehension to be a proof of
the sincerity of their love sometimes
lovers will even say that they knew they
were meant to be together because they
could communicate without needing to
speak but outside of the initial weeks
of love such romantic aspirations are a
pure catastrophe which lead lovers to a
bias against ever explaining themselves
and their desires with appropriate
patience and thoroughness faithfully for
our chances of happiness in the romantic
ideology love is understood to be an
enthusiasm rather than what it really is
a skill that needs to be learned
everyone hates reviews at work
but what deeply kind phenomena they
actually are compared with what goes on
at home
reviews are steeped in a culture of tact
one rather tough remark has to be
wrapped in at least seven compliments
work culture knows that people don't
improve and can't take new ideas on
board if they're feeling threatened and
humiliated home life finds us far less
able to be competent teachers
we're so panicked and frightened by the
thought that the other person can't do
what we want them to even if we haven't
actually ever explained it we take to
trying to teach them by slamming doors
and calling them idiots or worse
sadly no one's ever learnt very much
under conditions of hysteria furthermore
we're likely to feel that being taught
anything by a lover
contravenes the rules of love we think
we need to be loved just for being who
we are though we are all of course
terribly flawed we imagine that love has
nothing to do with education and that
the lover who tries to point something
out to us is therefore always just be
nasty rather than doing what all lovers
should in fact do which is their utmost
to improve those they care about through
their love
we rely on work of course but we'd
survive if it came to an end that's not
the feeling we often get around love
especially when there are a couple of
kids in a mortgage in common and the
more we depend on someone the more
alarmed we get by any disappointment at
their hands we aren't nastier around
love per se were just a whole lot more
dependent which can end up looking like
the same thing running a nuclear power
station or landing large jets is hardly
simple but one should insist still very
much easier than trying to be happy
around another human being in a sexual
relationship lasting many decades there
is simply nothing harder in this world
so complicated a we so higher our
expectations and so very poor is our
romantic culture at helping us to raise
the quality of our levels of patience
our insights our feedback sessions and
our training manuals no wonder we're
often really quite happy when it's
finally Monday morning again and we can
leave the house and do something
properly simple with our lives once
again
you